[Musique]
nous allons donc compter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures de
renard découvre un sous terre c'est là
de marbre
la femme du
et charmant et se montre bien
que non
[Musique]
c'est d'où vous venez vous étiez les
gens j'aurais il me semble bien des
reproches ça vous faire je crois que
vous ne voulez rien faire pour mettre
créa
seriez vous pas plus galants avec l'état
[Musique]
madame c'est volontiers plus souvent que
je viendrai vous rendre visite mais
pourquoi dont il en grains matile priant
m
il prétend que j'ai certains penchant
pour vous
vraiment rien
[Musique]
il dit que je cherche à prendre sa place
ici
[Musique]
on
en
nous ne retrouverons ma belle
[Musique]
et
où
[Musique]
en
oh
[Musique]